flight sk-1 five eight nine from
Stockholm to Brussels visibility is good
and there's a light breeze as the
aircraft approaches its destination
nothing at all out of the ordinary
onboard until that story oh that's the
glory all the beginning of the plane's
descent is the cure for young pyramids
big performance she's been a flight
attendant with a Scandinavian airline
for more than twenty years a few years
ago she began singing on board it was in
the autumn it was dark outside and
before takeoff and landing we always
turn off the lights it reminded me of a
love song and I just started singing
yen says it always works all of a sudden
the mood on board changes radically she
has in fact become rather famous among
business travellers in Northern Europe
they definitely recommend I fly a lot
but I've never experienced anything like
this before happening here there was
something special in the air the whole
time it's so nice and another wise
dismal working day you leave the plane
in an upbeat mood lovely
why don't what a great introduction to
Sweden I've not been here before I'm an
Australian to keep sounding good at an
altitude of 10,000 meters the flight
attendant practices at home especially
when she does her ironing the passengers
are often irritable annoyed or angry we
have to put them back in a good mood the
crew enjoys yen permits singing
performances as well they make everyone
on board feel relaxed you can tell the
people aren't expecting it when they
experience this little surprise the
atmosphere on board improves in seconds
wonderful mood develops yen is a lovely
person her singing makes our work easier
and makes everyone on board cheerful she
makes everything much easier for us
every time she's a great colleague and
I'm always happy when I'm scheduled to
fly with her a little good mood therapy
for stressed out frequent fliers that's
how you internet sees it when one
passenger was disembarking he approached
me I could see he wanted to say
something but I didn't know what and
then he put down his bags and hugged me
tight I looked at him tears were rolling
down his cheeks he said that really did
me good
oh my very thumb I was very touched it's
wonderful when people aren't afraid to
express these little feelings in CHEM it
hasn't been offered a record contract
yet but she knows she occasionally
manages to make a passenger's day